[Music]
gender is a term that clearly has had an
awful lot of use and it's also traveled
a very long distance in terms of the way
we think about it but is it still useful
or are we in a sense outgrowing it okay
well thank you I think it's important
before we get into the debate here to
make a very clear distinction between
the two terms gender and sex so these
two terms out there in the world are
always conflated often wrongly so
biological sex refers to physical
biological bodily characteristics it's a
descriptive label that we put on to
people's bodies usually at Birth based
on biological features and currently we
recognize female male and intersex as
those labels so gender however is not
biological gender is the term used to
refer to masculinity femininity
androgynous camp unicorn or whatever
other sorts of ways people might want to
define their expression and their style
and their personal identity it is deeply
felt it's a key part of most of our
identities and in that sense it is real
but it is not born it is made gender is
a social construct that changes over
time and place and culture babies are
not born macho or boyish or girlish
babies are not born liking football or
frocks they are not born with a
biological drive to sit with their legs
apart versus crossed they don't have a
fancy for long hair and makeup in the
womb they don't they're not born
neurologically predisposed to pursuing
either low-paid caring work or
construction apprenticeship
what is considered appropriately
masculine or feminine clothing jobs
hobbies roles changes in line with the
socio-economic and political climate
so while around the world babies have
been born with pretty similar bodies
pretty similar biological
characteristics forever
the same cannot be said for gender
gender fluxes and changes so it cannot
and should not be described as
biological or natural or fixed or in the
brain all these other sort of
essentialist claims that are sometimes
made for gender so coming back to the
question then of the debate I can see
why it may seem and feel radical to use
terms and claim identities such as
gender fluid or non-binary for example
but these labels can be
counterproductive because they can end
up strengthening the very institutions
that they suggest that they wish to take
apart so the category of non-binary for
example reinforces the binary in a sense
because in order for there to be a
non-binary there has to be a binary in
the first place and I would suggest
actually that gender comes naturally to
no one everyone works hard at their
gender most people are trying to be
masculine or feminine and worried that
they are not masculine or feminine
enough look at the billions spent on gym
membership beauty products cosmetic
surgery by men and women the numbers of
young people boys and girls self-harming
extreme dieting from younger and younger
ages suffering eating disorders taking
illegal muscle building steroids or
overtraining in the gym these brutal
statistics also illustrate that point
gender is a profoundly political
category it is intended to distinguish
within our system of sex rank so the
answer cannot be just to add more and
more categories to the rainbow of gender
if anywhere along the spectrum women are
still being oppressed by men women being
paid less because they have an F
on their birth certificate men being
refused parent or leave because they
have an M on theirs fetuses aborted
because they are girls men getting away
with rape this system of sex rank has to
end and that can only be done through
collective liberation movements it
cannot be done individually alone
through personal expression which calls
only for recognition of increasingly
increasingly diverse personal identities
so just to be clear that last point Finn
you are saying this struggle cannot be
carried out simply through individual
recognition of individual preference
there's a lot of good things about the
massive cultural shift we're seeing in
the understanding of the fixity of sex
sexuality gender and sex that's a really
interesting and powerful and real shift
but we mustn't throw the baby out with
the bathwater so to speak not to be
overly by a biological about it we
mustn't throw away collective liberation
movements because sadly we still need
them for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you